therefore is a prosperous industrial
city in eastern France cars trains and
streetcars are produced here immigrants
from the former French colonies in North
Africa have played an important role in
the city's success many came here to
take factory jobs in the 1970s and made
bail for their home they comprised some
10% of the city's population but now
they find themselves feeling unwelcome
in their own community following
comments made by mayor dummy an MS
Lowell he said that Balfour is
considering taking in refugees from Iraq
and Syria but for now only Christians I
don't want to take them in because
they're Christians but because they're
persecuted I'm surprised at the
criticism from the left-wing parties and
certain media organizations you get the
impression that because they're
Christians we have no right to take them
in protests decrying Islamophobia are
unwelcome maslow is quick to dismiss
them by publicly attacking his opponents
Muslim Brotherhood are known for their
provocations ms loathes remarks have
provoked outrage well beyond Balfour's
borders and been denounced by Frances
interior minister the mayor isn't giving
interviews at present but for bail for
his Muslim population in particular his
message has come through loud and clear
what's us I'm Algerian and have been
here 37 years if I could return to
Algeria and work I'd have left long ago
rather than deal with the racism here
it's got to stop
focus on it
Samiha Javert is one of the mayor's
biggest opponents born to an Algerian
family she's fought her way to the top
in Belfour and had a seat on the City
Council for years the socialist hopes to
combat the prevailing anti-islamic
sentiment which she believes is
politically motivated our mayor de meme
is Louis wing for national supporters
but that's a losing battle in which you
lose your values and your soul siva
Lopez una miz low and his republicans
are trying to attract supporters of
far-right parties like the phone Asuna
which won a record 24% of the vote here
in local elections this year my SLO is
looking to do better in upcoming
regional elections and his gamble could
pay off co- non-christian refugees we
can't be sure they don't belong to is
I'm with mr. mosz low that's all the
mayor also has the support of the
Catholic Church together the city and
the diocese have set up an organization
to welcome Christian refugees but church
representatives say they're not
discriminating against refugees of other
religions
negocios Christians we have a special
fraternity with our Christian brothers
but we know that in Syria and Iraq there
are also other minorities that are being
persecuted like yellow cedar Tomino he
takes something that includes the CDs
the Kurds and other Muslim minorities
will welcome anyone sent to us like who
you Sookie knew so all were you in the
coming once France expects to take in
some 24,000 such refugees that's a
relatively small number compared with
the amount being taken in by other
European countries still racist
sentiment is growing in France in many
French cities Muslims and Jews keep to
themselves to avoid confrontations but
that hasn't been the case in Bell for
the mayor's comments are regrettable
fourth but you must remember that many
in Belfour were refugees themselves well
for took in many Alsatians in eighteen
71 after the franco-german war across
Europe there are people who've been
forced to flee their homes often they
were treated well and we must continue
to do that Pompeii by trickle tear but
the growing intolerance towards the
Muslim population is increasing tensions
and sparking racist incidents bus
drivers here mobbed a Muslim colleague
who showed up at their soccer club
wearing a jacket with Arabic writing on
it
Samia javert blames dummy um is low for
such incidents by demonizing minorities
she says he's failed as a mayor motion
by Cavalli Nancy Baraka DCO I'd like to
return to the way things were in our
city
when comments were measured and balanced
now people take positions that are
divisive and create tensions it was too
hokey we've never had tensions here I'd
like to revert to our peaceful
traditions overni I said - it's as if
Teddy stone maramures Lowe has driven a
wedge between Christians and Muslims
here so it's ironic that around half of
Balfour's Muslim voters helped him get
elected it seems unlikely he'll receive
their vote next time around